very happy to be here I love doing
stand-up I love performing but if I'm
being honest this is not the plan I had
for my life I went to college where as a
sociology major with separate
concentrations in creative writing and
philosophy so obviously my plan was to
sell weed that is what those degrees I
could fund I sold weed for years and I
stopped because I was scared of getting
caught because this is the early 2000s
before is legal anywhere the big news
story was the NSA and the feds
wiretapping cell phones and I was
selling primarily to white girls in
college and no one cares less about
being discreet with the illegal activity
than white girls in college I had one
girl calling my phone and leave a
message just on my voicemail like hey
Noah it's Kimberly heard you were
selling weed now I was talking dog you
said you had good stuff at good prices
call me back so I can buy some weed baby
like damn all the things that take me
out of the game Kimberly the wider we've
been away shorter series they're more
white people in Baltimore saying
Kimberly would got stringer Bell by
episode two politics of identity are
tricky though I know that I personally
identify as a Jewish man and I support
anyone's right to believe or not believe
whatever they want but I will say this I
don't think enough people think about
Jesus from the Jewish perspective this
is gonna go great just hear me out
stay with me Jews already had a god they
really liked when one day Jesus came
around claiming to be God imagine
spending your entire life working at a
company for a boss you really liked when
one day the boss's son came in claiming
to be your new boss we were like no
you're not we have a boss we like the
boss you're not the boss and he's like
I'm the boss like no you're not we have
a boss we like the boss you're not the
boss and he's like I'm the boss they're
like no you're not and he's like oh yeah
watch this then he goes and fixes the
printer brings back enough coffee and
doughnuts from the break room for the
entire office and all of a sudden some
of the young employees are looking
around like maybe he is the new boss so
the old employees they get nervous and
they go and tell HR the Romans they
don't want him to get fired they just
want to written up on his file they just
want someone to take notice of the fact
that he's causing trouble in the break
room but HR fires him HR fires him but
everyone blames the employees
so then he goes and starts his own new
company and offers everyone free health
care and all you have to do to get hired
is acknowledge that he's the new boss
and he got fired for your mistakes
[Applause]
listen even if you don't like the joke
you have to admit that the analogy is
perfect I like to speak in terms of
analogies because I think that it makes
material more relatable that's something
that I actually learned as an elementary
school teacher yes that is correct when
I stopped selling weed I transitioned
naturally in the teaching fourth grade
and one thing that I noticed as a fourth
grade teacher is that in America we
expect children to know things about the
English language that most adults don't
even know there anyone in here that
could name the four sentence types you
see that roomful of intelligent adults
no one in here can tell me what nine and
ten-year-olds across the country will be
tested on the four sentence types
declarative imperative exclamatory
interrogative declarative make a
statement imperative given order
exclamatory show emotion interrogative
ask a question now I understand you
cannot teach children's material to a
roomful of adults using children's
examples so I now teach you the four
sentence types having a very adult
conversation
declarative make a statement I am
pregnant
imperative give an order get rid of that
baby
exclamatory show emotion you said you'd
pull out
interrogative ask a question why would
you listen to me you guys been fantastic
thank you so much
you